One of Thor's funniest friends will return
for the Asgardian hero's next cinematic venture.
During a recent interview, director Taika
Waititi, who helmed the franchise-reviver
Thor: Ragnarok and will also direct Thor:
Love and Thunder, confirmed the return of
a fan-favorite character.
His name, of course, is Korg, and he's coming
back to the big screen for more Thor.
Though his conversation with Jimmy Kimmel
was mostly about his buzzy new film Jojo Rabbit,
Waititi briefly touched on Thor: Love and
Thunder, which is when the director made this
exciting announcement.
"My character's coming back.
Korg."
A member of an ancient group of rock-like
humanoid entities, Korg made his official
debut in Thor: Ragnarok, but he actually wasn't
the first Kronan to appear in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe.
The MCU canon details that a prominent member
of the Marauders, the coalition of invaders
that attacked the Nine Realms including Thor's
home world of Asgard, was a Kronan warrior.
That Kronan tried to throw down with Thor
during the battle on Vanaheim in 2013's Thor:
The Dark World, but the God of Thunder took
him down.
In 2017's Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 2,
two Kronans were shown fighting when the Quadrant
whizzed past them.
Many fans have speculated that one of the
two Kronans was Korg, who wound up getting
sent to Sakaar and was forced to compete in
the Grandmaster's Contest of Champions.
In Thor: Ragnarok, Korg meets Thor in a holding
area where the Grandmaster's champions prepare
to fight.
"I tried to start a revolution, but I didn't
print enough pamphlets, so hardly anyone showed
up except my mum and her boyfriend, who I
hate."
The two quickly become allies and Korg ultimately
stages a mutiny against the Grandmaster.
Korg escapes from Sakaar and pops up again
to help defeat the villainous Hela on the
Rainbow Bridge leading into Asgard.
After the fiery demon Surtur rises again and
destroys Asgard at the end of Thor: Ragnarok,
Korg sticks around with his godly buddy.
Though he didn't appear in Avengers: Infinity
War, Korg emerged as a lucky survivor of Thanos'
Snap in Avengers: Endgame.
With half the universe's population gone,
Korg and Miek reunited with Thor and lived
together in New Asgard.
For five years, Korg provided emotional support
as Thor struggled with his feelings, and Korg
even lent a hand in the final fight against
Thanos.
All this is to say that Korg has been an important
part of Thor's life for many years, and that's
not going to change in Thor: Love and Thunder,
which will likely start off by filling us
in on what's happened since we last saw Korg
and Thor.
Embracing his bigger body and knowing that
he's still worthy of being a hero, Thor joined
forces with the Guardians of the Galaxy in
the final moments of Endgame, when the galaxy-saving
crew were about to ship out in search of Gamora.
Meanwhile, Korg headed home to New Asgard,
where Valkyrie is now king.
While we can't speculate on what might happen
in the upcoming third Guardians of the Galaxy
movie which might see Thor in the mix, we
can theorize that Thor: Love and Thunder will
see Thor returning home to New Asgard and
having a happy reunion with Korg and Valkyrie.
Waititi has confirmed that Love and Thunder
will introduce the MCU's first openly bisexual
character in Valkyrie, who will be looking
for her queen in the new movie.
It seems safe to assume that Love and Thunder
might see Korg serving as one of Valkyrie's
royal advisors, helping her find a lucky lady
to aid in ruling New Asgard.
Whichever way the cookie crumbles, Korg is
sure to bring plenty of laughs and some rocky
shoulders to cry on should anyone need them
in the new Thor flick.
The only bad news about Thor: Love and Thunder
thus far, however, is that fans will have
to wait until November 5, 2021 to see it.
Until then, there's undoubtedly plenty of
exciting news to come for the God of Thunder.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.